you know he used to say he knew
with people anymore when they became
contorted and ugly in his paintings this
must have been right right at the end
these paintings I did that what you do
you're a painter that's what I like to
do but you know we're bartender how's
the acting it's good I kind of took a
break from it I'm focusing on my writing
right now a painter and an actor I hope
you guys have sober bank accounts not
that they'll ever be anything in your
girl seems really nice
I met her in a woodworking class taking
woodworking huh no Cecilia what are you
grateful for oh I prefer to keep my
gratitude to myself thank you before I
came to pick you up tonight I actually
wrote a short story what was a story
about the worst first date ever do you
believe that men and women must always
play games I'm too old to play games I
wish to enjoy the wonder of your body Oh
what happens on this tape the guy dies
you were freaked out about moving in
together I'm a little scared about
moving in together but that that's why I
want to move in with you because you
call me on stuff like that but that's
why I'm afraid to move in with you
because you just stuff like that
this is your costume I'm a my naked guy
in a barrel why I don't know man lately
I feel like they've been this like
growing distance between us never
relationship got the lover and the loved
and the loved always has the upper hand
my man I go and build a process of
schools for the impoverished children of
nemedia it turned into a school girl
around this guy wait he always needs
everybody to like him all the time he's
a lot of attention
man oh she got hit by train that sounds
a little crazy that's crazy tongue
[Music]
- for everyone just a club the whole
knife how are you know right now I guess
it's good that you're not just back
right
someone once said it's better to have
loved and lost and not to have loved it
all I want to punch that guy in the face
but the truth is he's right because in
spite of all the desperation and the
pain when it's great when it's really
great it's all worth it
[Music]
you
you